today we're gonna make a cheeseburger
double cheeseburger I always cooked my
burgers in cast-iron around a flattop
when I was a kid my parents owned a
diner and everything was cooked on
probably a you know three-foot flat top
grill all the eggs omelettes everything
was on there and all the burgers were on
there as well so I mean I kind of grew
up with that style of burger and that
flavor of burger I just really enjoy
that caramelized crisp across from a
flattop or cast-iron good cheese burgers
it's not difficult to do it just takes a
lot of thought if you think about how
you assemble it what you use you know
you always season your meat you don't
have to get too crazy with it
I always bribed my own meat I care it a
little bit it's got a little bit of
bacon added into it and that's kind of
the elevated touches I guess I bring to
it but it's really really simple you
know anybody should be able to do it if
you don't want to grind your meat you
could use store-bought meat by all means
you don't and make sure you salt it
always seasoned it so we're going to
roll these in two to three ounce balls
put them on the cast-iron to cook for a
little bit and then smash them down
almost treat it like a piece of fish
caramelize one side really hard then
flip it over just kind of kiss it for
one second on the other side put the
cheese on and then take them right out
and start building the burger I
generally find that about six ounces of
meat is enough you know I think it's all
about how you build it and the bun to
meat ratio I really like thin patties
and burgers I don't like a thick patty
it should just be kind of a really thin
kind of greasy piece of meat on a bun
but still really juicy because it's
cooking a lot of fat it's cooked really
fast you know that's that's to me that's
perfect